the iPhone se4 is coming and we just got
some brand new leaks showing that it's
going to be much better than we
anticipated so in this video we're going
to talk about the new leaks the
information that we already know along
with some of the features that we're
gonna get on the updated phone and the
price tag and the release date so a lot
of stuff coming up here now the iPhone
SE lineup has been kind of boring at
least the last few iterations at first
it was okay but recently it's just so
far behind with the design that is five
six seven years old now and a camera
from the iPhone 8 that it just doesn't
make sense for most people because of
that a lot of people are excited for a
newer refreshed SE that will actually be
a reasonable phone for 2023 24. this
kind of era that we are in even though
the current one has an a15 processor in
it so it's very powerful when you take a
look at the battery life it is terrible
even with the iPhone 12 having about 30
battery remaining and the same thing
with the 13 Mini compared to the SE and
the camera quality like I mentioned is
the same compared to 2021 which even the
pixel 4A absolutely destroyed well that
is going to change because the SE will
finally be a good phone again now we had
some Rumors in the past that are coming
to light more so now that the iPhone SE
will finally be ditching that old tiny
LCD screen for an OLED that's coming in
at 6.1 inches and that is basically the
same size as the iPhone 14. this could
be a good thing or a bad thing depending
on your perspective you guys can comment
down on below but a lot of people that
were buying iPhone se's are those that
were using lower price Android phones
and they wanted to get into the Apple
ecosystem without spending a lot of
money but being 2023 now most of them do
not want to buy something that is so
outdated and of course with the other
issues that I brought up now as far as
size if we put these two side by side
the difference isn't massive as far as
footprint but the 14 is wider and it is
a lot thicker as well this is one reason
why some people still buy an iPhone SE
because it's so thin and lightweight and
personally I think they've been great if
they just use the iPhone 12 or 13 minis
frame and made that the SC because that
would still give you a nice balance of
size and looking at that battery chat
that I showed off well the battery life
on the 13 mini was actually quite good
similar to the I iPhone 12 and of course
with the newer processor that would get
even better but nope it looks like we're
gonna have the same flat sided design on
the new se4 as the iPhone 14 and with
Apple's market research most people are
gonna want something that's a little bit
larger but thankfully there are going to
be some other updates one thing we saw
is that the se4 is likely going to be
the first phone that is using Apple's
in-house 5G modem and this was mentioned
by qualcomm's CEO themselves for
2024. now that means it's going to cost
Apple less money to create it instead of
having to buy it from Qualcomm and we
might actually get some better
efficiency as well and with the se3
Apple actually bumped up the price tag
to make up for the 5G that they added
into it now as far as the processor I
would expect Apple to be using the a16
or maybe even the a17 in there because
typically when they update the SC they
put in the latest processor and that
makes the longevity of these devices
very good and it also helps with battery
life being such a thin and light device
now as far as the cameras we are still
going to have a single lens camera on
the back just like all the other SC so
even though we're going to have this
kind of a modern shape it'll have a
single camera but the good thing is it's
going to be much much better than the
se3 if you guys see the difference in
camera size there it is massive now I
expect the se4 to have a 12 megapixel
camera in it it will not go up to the 48
like we're gonna see with the newer
iPhone so you are going to be behind but
it will still be a nice Improvement now
we know that the iPhone 15 is going to
be getting rid of the Notch from the 14
and getting the dynamic Island which is
going to be sweet but because of that
apple is going to be able to put the
notch into the iPhone se4 so it's going
to be a generation behind now we have
more info from this latest leak saying
that it is going to be featuring an
action button just like the new iPhone
so it's going to get similar across the
lineup and this is one thing that we
were not expecting on the se4 and
another way that it is going to be
getting better with that it is also
going to be getting USB type c so it's
going to make it match up with the rest
of the lineup it's going to be Universal
now I expected to still have slow
transfer speeds on this budget device
but it is nice that it is getting that
and we also have info that different
manufacturers are actually bidding right
now to make those OLED displays so
that's the last big update OLED instead
of LCD now what is going to happen to
the price tag for a while we had the SE
at 399 then it bumped up well personally
I think that it's going to bump up to
499 dollars and that's going to be one
reason why they're using the iPhone 4
teen style design instead of the apple
10r design that was leaked for a while
just because they want to refresh it and
be able to make some more money from the
device with inflation with Apple trying
to make more money as less iPhones are
selling that's going to help them out
and I think that with a more modern
design that's much better with much
better battery life it's going to be a
phone at 500 bucks that is going to
tempt a lot of Android users to switch
over and have a good enough device to do
that instead of wanting to stick with
Android now the only negative is we've
gotten some updates on the release date
and I really hope this is wrong because
it doesn't seem to make sense to me but
that the device has been delayed until
2025.
now the reason why I say it doesn't make
sense is because we had the iPhone SE 2
in 2020 then in 2022 we had the se3 and
2024 Springtime would match up perfectly
and then by that time the iPhones were
upgraded have been upgraded to the
iPhone 15 lineup and that's going to
give Apple a much better device to sell
earlier on instead of waiting for later
and especially if companies are already
bidding on uh the display to manufacture
it it just makes sense to be a year and
a half out you guys let me know your
thoughts is that a phone that you would
want to buy and to use or would you
prefer them to use the mini body like I
would thank you guys for watching click
that Circle about to subscribe check out
one of those great videos right over
there this has been Max and I'll see you
in the next one
[Music]
thank you